my guest tonight is an actor and model
who has starred in one of the biggest so
bad it's good movies of all time the
room he tours the nation with the film's
director writer co-star Tommy was so and
has recently written a book about the
experience called the disaster artist my
life inside the room the greatest bad
movie ever made
thank God he has embarrassed have so
humor about it than Tommy was so or else
he wouldn't be here with me right now
please welcome the very awesome Greg
Sestero how are you sir very good I'm
glad to be here so anyway how's your sex
life alright I stay away from staircases
from now on but uh you know banging him
there you don't put it inside
bellybuttons no no that was never my
thing tommy was a pro at that ok ok it
is about to him yeah yeah and I know
some people like it tight I just don't
know that it's very interesting
impregnated Lisa's navel at some point
but find out about that that's where
babies come from right you know when you
hear people quote stuff like that I come
up and say like oh hi mark I'm sure any
of that stuff does it get a twinge into
your eye or do you really embrace it I
think it's pretty fun I mean I'm a big
movie fan you know I'm sure if I walk by
George McFly one point I'd say the same
thing so I think it's pretty fun you
know I think it's cool every time I see
um a lot like we've joked about and if
we made some quotes and stuff like that
you seem very
you seem very accepting of something
that many people in your situation would
want to forget but you seem to really
embrace it and really love it what is it
that makes you love it so much and enjoy
I think when I first met Tommy in that
acting class in San Francisco he was
somebody that I just saw is this really
fascinating character that you just
enjoy watching him exist in life so
this movie was an extension of that so
it's like okay he's gonna make a movie
oh my god I gotta be there to see how he
does it so I was kind of it was a kind
of a big joke to me you know the whole
time so now that people are embracing it
you know I was kind of like the first
fan I guess you could say of how this
whole thing went down so to me you gotta
have a sense of humor about it it's it's
so hilarious and then people enjoy it so
I you know I can't really complain about
that you you got in you you want to be
you want to be an actor but you actually
start off as a model and you transfer it
into acting up what was the attraction
to acting that modeling didn't give you
it's yeah it's so funny with the whole
modeling thing they say oh if you if you
go on it's a it's a way to break into
the business as if you're modeling
making an actor but it's not the case at
all because a lot of people think models
can't act for good reason um so I was
just I was an opportunity that was
offered to me and I and I I took it and
figured someone said that it's it's the
starving waiter job that allows you to
eat lobster I don't know that's even
true but yeah I wished I thought it was
a way to get into acting and it totally
wasn't I mean the odd jobs you have to
do modeling it's such a crazy business
that uh yeah it was an experience to say
the least
um you of course have been in such not
just the room but other demanding roles
like in retro puppet master and Days of
Our Lives uh roles a lot of people
probably wouldn't be aiming for when you
got roles like that was that something
where you got discouraged or you just
say that's just part of the game you
know what I moved to LA my fourth
audition I booked the lead in this movie
retro puppet master I had never really
had a speaking part on camera and we're
shooting in Romania I figure you know
why not why not do it I had no idea
really what it was gonna be I didn't
watch any of the sequels or you know
prequels and I uh I watched it I watched
when I was like oh God should I maybe
cancel this but uh it was just kind of
whatever was offered you know at the
time and I went out for a lot of cool
scripts that never even ended up getting
made and uh yeah just part of the game I
guess trying to survive you know trying
to survive the business um you said that
he met Tommy in a in an acting class
corrected just at the ball places did to
tell me just tell me the experience of
meeting that man
so I'm sitting in this dark basement on
Sutter Street in San Francisco that
sounds like where one would meet Tommy
was oh but you know yeah and I just
trying to figure out is this guy vampire
is he a caveman like what's this guy's
deal and he goes up on stage very
commanding presence see everyone's just
kind of watching him and he picks around
backstage for kind of a long time we're
all sitting there he comes out with a
you know Stewie slams it down he starts
performing the Shakespearean sonnet
everybody's like just in awe I mean
people that are normally really quiet or
like laughing they're trying to
communicate II know laughter and I'm
just I'm Senor gun what's what's he
gonna do next the teacher was very
intimidating so I wondered how he was
gonna interact with her and so when it
came to an end
uh she just was like what are you trying
to do and he said I performed the sauna
she's like no you're not he had this
really intense argument that was very
entertaining and I felt like he
confronted her and nobody else had done
that and I was like you know what I
should do a scene with this guy I need
to learn some stuff from him
so I approached him I was like hey let's
be scene partners and he's like he
looked at me like I was crazy
hahaha which clearly you were but it
worked out I was I was I was crazy I was
19 I was down and out I almost gotten
the role in this movie I was struggling
trying to make it to LA and I was like
what do I got to lose I'm at Ground Zero
I'm gonna take a chance there so
fascinating you you saw this guy that
you know you've just said you know
perform this very crazy sonnet and and
instead of seeing someone that you just
said Abbot's but nopal whatever you
actually saw something that other people
were doing something that was dead um
very captivating you know in his own way
entertaining presence on stage it wasn't
classic in any way shape or form but I I
think characters you're really you know
really interesting I figured why not he
clearly does stuff that is not done by
other people I mean like in Andy's and
for example in the room he makes
decisions like he has some lines in some
scenes like the scene with the dog said
backwards or out of order uh there's
several writing moments or plot devices
that go nowhere and there's even a scene
where you guys are playing football in
tuxes like it's an everyday occurrence
and it's never explained why making this
movie what is your thought process
through all this bizarreness sake every
day is an adventure you just didn't know
what was coming I mean he would have
ideas come to him where you know today
you have to shave your beard and we're
gonna do a tuxedo scene and play
football what about that and I'm like
okay we just got a roll with it he put
as many topics into the film and it's
breast cancer football tuxedos like all
these things come in that aren't really
tied in with the plot in any way it's
just all these kind of social issues he
wanted to pack into this film to make it
as important as possible and so you're
just kind of along for the
roller-coaster and hopefully you don't
you know end up with your head cut off
you you're a to an old it seems to be
very optimistic just just take the ride
go for it take the ticket take the ride
um when you do scenes like the love
scene in there we have to expose quite a
bit does that ever get you nervous or is
that just another part of the game yeah
I didn't you know what the big thing
with this movie when I when I said I was
gonna do it reluctantly was I'm only
gonna have my shirt off so cuz tommy was
big on revealing a lot and so I was like
pants stay on these are no sure no
problem so the other loves teens were
still very very painful to watch I mean
you're shooting in a small stage it's
about 120 degrees no one's really
comfortable you're on this staircase
that's incredibly uncomfortable that I
don't think it's ever
you think people you know I've done it
there who even fantasizes about that
it's not it's there's nothing appealing
about it I mean if you just head a
little ways up there's a bed right up
there I mean it's it makes me much of a
joy you can get caught if you're sitting
right there on the staircase the door
opens you're you there's no excuses you
can make so the whole thing was just
kind of awkward and it really looks that
way on screen I mean it's the part when
the movie comes on where I just bolt for
the exit no I got forward III will
disagree a little bit that there's no
excuse because if you were to say why
would we be making love on a staircase a
lap you would say I don't know I have
nothing that can validate that so I
disagree a little bit with it maybe it
was actually smarter than we're giving
Tommy credit for that's true or maybe I
think Mark was just so overcome with
passion for Lea so that he could
whatever yeah she was just too beautiful
tell it's totally possible um obviously
you you had this fascinating
relationship with Tommy Wiseau you seem
to have a good friendship but you're
definitely not below throwing a few
punches here and there or at the very
least acknowledging what you see about
this guy
just in general well how would you
describe your relationship with him
because it does seem very unique but
also it seems like you will throw the
jokes in but it's still very loving yeah
I it's definitely there's I have a lot
of you know appreciation and in some
ways admiration for Tommy for sticking
through this whole process for this many
years and making the project you wanted
to make I do see it as for what it is
it's just a very bizarre cinematic
experience and I think that's nothing to
take away from anything that Tommy tried
to do or accomplished I think it's just
fun in the culture of movies to you know
treat this film for what it is and but
yeah I think I with especially with the
book it was important for me to be as
honest as possible about what my
experience was like and also be you know
respectful towards what Tommy's privacy
and what he would want
yes Tommy read the book he's read parts
of it he said I support 50%
cook is 50% always red or as 50% of why
that's a good question I'm waiting for
for the other shoe to drop
what he's gonna say you know I'm not
gonna ask the obvious questions that
everybody has about timing but was so
where is he from why does he talk the
way he talks
what is he uh but I do what do you feel
is his thought process what is his
logical reasoning with how to deal with
the world in general because clearly
nobody else understands it and I think
the person who can possibly come the
closest to understanding it is you what
is his thought process yeah it's it's
funny there's a chapter in the book
called Tommy's planet um and I really
believe the way he interprets things the
way he thinks there's no one else out
there like him and I noticed that very
early on he told me a story that one of
his goals was to have like his own
planet his own casino is you know his
own everything and he canted me this pen
that he had made called Tommy's planet
and he just is totally different I mean
he comes up with lines like with the
doggie thing like a lot of the best
things about Tommy are they're
improvised like those Moe the best
moments in the film are just him having
a reaction and and I think that's what's
great about the room as you're seeing
something that you couldn't really find
anywhere else because nobody thinks like
him and nobody would have put this much
energy into making a film without
getting anybody else's opinion I just
totally bankrolling the whole thing and
pushing it until people finally
responded to it so I think that's what's
kept the room going for 10 years is that
no one thinks speaks or acts like him
and I think people just are trying to
figure out what really it is do you feel
you've understood him better the more
you've been with him or has it just
become more of a mystery I understood a
lot more things but there's there's
always parts that I feel like just keep
turning over new mysteries and new
mysteries it's like you just keep
getting to these dead ends so I've kind
of come to the fact that there's just
things I'm never going to find out and
that's part of the fun I guess yeah um
what is something that people don't know
about Tommy was
so that you think they should know I
think that Tommy is there's a part in
that's very human and very endearing and
just really really enjoyable I think he
comes off as you know this vampire alien
looking guy in the movie and it's you
know when his appearance is the
sunglasses but yeah there's just this
human side to him that's just it's so
fun going through these experiences with
like getting on a plane or watching go
through airport security he's just got
this really there's just no one else
really like him and what is something
about you that people don't know that
you think they should know um that I am
nothing like mark in the room you're not
adulterer come on man I look to you I'm
like dude you totally cheat us what yeah
I think yeah I'm probably the opposite
of Mark so for better for worse yeah you
know I was gonna say you don't hang any
pictures of spoons on your wall and that
just leads me to a question I think now
what is up with the spoon on the wall
yeah the spoon on the wall or spoon only
on the table there it's basically they
just didn't have time to put a change of
picture and put you know take out the
stock photo which is what it was they
were they're trying to get a picture of
Johnny and Lisa in there which would
have made sense that they'd have framed
pictures of their couple on the table
but you know Tommy's like we don't have
time so they just left this frame
picture of a spoon in there so now it's
off boom hog refer should be pretty
happy that all these screenings you know
all over having fire these all these uh
plastic spoons oh if only we could
remember like the photography was fun we
could do a plug for it just right now if
you want pictures of people like
business would go booming for that like
just that spoon like that pictures
somebody died just that Oh a picture of
a spoon you never thought it would have
inspired that it'll turn to like this
great kitchen art like the dogs playing
poker and stuff yeah so everyone have
this picture of a spoon it's like yeah
you don't get it yeah so ah play we as
name it may we'll get the future they
will put play go forward be like I took
that picture yes oh
um you know you got this this book this
disaster artist obviously you really
want to tell this story what made you
what made you actually want to write it
down and share it with everybody
uh ever since I made this movie I've
always been asked why what was the
purpose why were you in it what were you
thinking
and I just felt to do the story justice
for Tommy and myself is really just to
tell the whole story of how crazy this
ride was that it's actually a lot
crazier than the movie itself and I felt
more of those stories that I told people
um they really responded to them so I
felt I felt compelled by the material to
tell it that it's not just this bad
movie and just the making of a bad movie
but it's really a story about an
unlikely friendship and a very surreal
take on the American dream that I felt
like I hadn't heard before I've noticed
that you have a pretty good impression
of Tommy was so even just the way sits
on it was very impressive would you be
willing to say five phrases in your
Tommy Wiseau voice sure uh the first one
is it's a me Mario it's a me Mario the
next one is Luke I am your father
look I am your father the next one is I
am the very model of a modern
major-general and the very model of the
major model general and you mispronounce
it which is just like um I love that uh
and the final one is sparkle Sparkle
Sparkle sparkle sparkles
Barbeau you should really go on tour
with that I'm telling you think reigned
in my memory at this plant it's I've
heard like two I've heard a lot of
impressions that has a very good
impression um so you've gone through uh
you found success being both a writer
and an actor in a very unusual strange
totally different way uh for other
people looking to just get recognition
or recognise any of that
as either an actor or a writer or both
what would you recommend for them it's
really weird it's the it's the things
that you least expect to come out that
do I mean with the room I didn't expect
anything from it I had worked on things
auditioned for movies that thought would
go somewhere and it was the room that
people really responded to so I don't
know it's it you know I've never been
into quote-unquote bad movies I didn't
even know there was a market for them
but I would say just get out there and
try and do as much as you can you know I
randomly decided to take that acting
class in San Francisco I could have
stayed home and not push myself to go
out and do that and it brought me on
this crazy adventure so you just don't
know what what's out there waiting for
you that could change your life I mean
this is this isn't an idea obviously I
would have loved to have made a movie
like Inception or something that that I
really respect and would be passionate
about but you know it's the room oddly
and this whole experience gives me a
chance to be creative and I can't really
complain about that so I'm gonna be
honest as soon as you send cept and I
immediately got an image of mark just
look around like what's going on give up
what's going on here wait wait what are
you doing what do you do that would have
been great but I think Tom Hardy took
that over I'm sure you audition Yeah
right um
just the whole experience it sounds like
you're very positive about it you're
very upbeat if you had to sum it up in a
sentence just everything making the room
and what has come of it in one sentence
I would just hum it up truth is stranger
than fiction nicely put I like to have
my interviews with the same two polar
opposite questions here the first one
being what is the toughest thing either
professional or personal that you've
ever gone through and how did you get
through it um well I'm gonna give a
little bit more of a shallow experience
I uh when I was trying to survive you
know as a model I got hired in Las Vegas
to be Tarzan
really and the the idiot that I am I
thought it would meant I was going to
wear a costume at a convention so it's
like oh nobody will see me I'll get paid
to work awesome at a convention so I
drove five hours to Vegas 5:00 a.m.
arrived they hand me a loincloth and
they're like this is what you need to
wear in front of an entire convention
and I kind of went to the bathroom
looked in the mirror and cried and it
was like am I going to do this am I
going to head back so uh I manned up and
I wore a loincloth
at a convention for two days two days
like the most embarrassing job what kind
of convention needs you to dress as
Tarzan it was it was like a food
convention or they would come relation
accompany the Tarzan company the owners
of tar the Tarzan brand were starting
energy bars so they needed a Tarzan to
be there to sell them or to at least
inspire them and I just got I rolled the
entire time and asked if I was like a
dancer from Thunder Down Under I'm like
no I'm just trying to survive here and
get this paycheck and get out of town so
it was I kept the loincloth just to
remind me don't end up here so it was it
was pretty brutal
before I ask the final question I just
had to know what did you think a Tarzan
costume what daddy
that is exactly that's the best question
of it because the joke was on me I mean
the whole point Tarzan is this in the
junk jungle he doesn't have a costume so
I was just a it was a just a very stupid
moment on my on my behalf
paycheck I was looking pretty good
wasn't I I paid the price well with that
said what is the proudest thing again
either professional or personal that you
have ever done in your life um I'd say a
big highlight was I'm a huge Star Wars
fan you know who isn't but when the room
showed at the Ziegfeld Theatre in 2010
it sold out the entire entire theater
and I had overheard somebody say that
that was the first time that had
happened since the re-release Star
so I thought it was kind of a was kind
of a amazing moment I mean it was I
accepted it for what it was I was very
aware that this wasn't Star Wars but I
think the fact that being part of
anything that brings that many people
together with something that was cool it
is very very cool the book again is the
disaster artist it is sold where all
good books are sold and banned books as
well I'm sure yeah but it is an awesome
book go check it out my guess was Greg
Sestero this is the part where we talk
to each other and like we still have
other things to say you know it's just
yeah and we laugh we laugh a lot do a
big laugh with me
ah what a story mark
good look good yeah awesome that's great
and that is it great questions yeah
perfect blend of kind of